[Music]
we heard your news
juilliard congrats that's incredible
you're thinking of my sister b
she's going to julia next year what
makes vivian the star
just always be there for you
and you whatever you are
what if i could be more but if i could
be great all i need is a chance to prove
myself
[Music]
moira wilson was one of the finest
musicians ever to grace this academy
we have decided to rerun the senior
concerto competition in her memory
i stole nora's theory book she carved
symbols all over the wall and threw
herself at a third floor window
she was brilliant the competition was a
big opportunity
i have to beat her
[Music]
on
i've been reading it studying it
assurance
like it's talking to me it's taking
control
triumph you stole my peace
i knew you were jealous everybody else
does too
something's up with you tools i won't be
there to pick up the pieces
music is a blood sport
you really want that spotlight you
wouldn't let anything get in your way
not even your sister
[Music]
what if i could be more what if i could
be great
[Music]
do